اخذت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي 19
فلسطينيين من المناطق متفرقه في الضفه
الغربيه ليله الماضيه وفجر اليوم وقال
نادي الاسير الفلسطيني ان الاعتقالات جرت
في بيت امر وحلحول شمال الخليل
دهشه كما ذكرنا وبلده حوسان وبلدتي بيت
سيرا ودير عمار غرب مدينه رام الله وبلده
العيزريه قضاء مدينه القدس وقال نادي
الاسيرنا المعتقلين نقل الى مراكز اعتقال
لتحقيق معهم بتهمه ممارسه انشطه تهدف الى
مقاومه الاحتلال
في اثناء هذا مات قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي حوالي 30 منشاه تجاريه مختلفه
في بلده حزما شمال الشرقيه شرق القدس
المحتله
بلديه الاحتلال البلده عند منتصف الليل
وشرعت بعمليه هدم للمنشات الواقعه على
الشارع الرئيسي بالقرب من احد حواجز
الاحتلال العسكريه المقامه عند مدخل مدينه
القدس من الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه
ضمن مناطق الجيم في الضفه الغربيه لكن
البلديه الاحتلال القدس تسعى الى ضمن
المنطقه لنفوذها
حزمه
وليد العمري وليد عمليه الهدم التي طالت
30 منشئه حيث توجد طفلهنا الى ما حولت هذا
المكان
هذا مشهد يضاف هو الاخر الى التصعيد
الاحتلال ضد الفلسطينيين هنا في قلب بلده
حزمه شمالي القدس المحتله قوات الاحتلال
خلال الليل وفجر اليوم قامت بهدم العديد
من المنشات هنا احداها في قلب البلده على
الجانب الجنوبي من الشارع الذي يعبر من
قلب بلده حزمه بتعتبر سلطات الاحتلال ان
هذا الجزء من الشارع هو تابع لبلديه القدس
لذلك ارسلت جرافاتها وقامت بهدم مثل هذه
المنشئه منشات اخرى في مناطق متفرقه
بذريعه انها غير قانونيه من وجهه نظرها
هذه المنشات التي تستخدم بعضها هناك حتى
حظائر اغنام بالاضافه الى ذلك همم ويعتاج
منها العديد من قائمه منذ سنوات طويله همم
قامت بهدمها بعد منتصف الليل دون ان توجه
حتى اختارات بذلك لاصحابها او لسكانها هي
منشات قائمه
مقابل منازل المواطنين انفسهم وليست هي
طارئه في الفتره الاخيره كانت قبل ان نحو
عام سلطات الاحتلال قد هدمت عده منشات
قريبه من الحاجز العسكري على الشارع
الرئيسي في منطقه قريبه من هنا لكن هذه
المره هي دخلت في قلب بلده حزما وبعضها
موجود في قلب البلده والبعض الاخر على
الشارع الرئيسي كما قلت هذا جزء من
التصعيد الاحتلالي الذي شهدته الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هذه الليله وفجر اليوم حيث تم
اعتقال 16 فلسطينيه من انحاء المتفرقه لكن
ابرز الاحداث كانت في بلده قباطيها جنوب
جنين وكذلك في مخيم الدهيشه جنوبيه مدينه
بيت لحم وبلدته حسام وقد اصيب مواطنين
بجراح خطيره بجراء اطلاق النار عليهما من
قوات الاحتلال حيث كانت هناك مواجهات وفي
بعض الاحيان تخللها ايضا تبادل لاطلاق
النار لكن القوات التي دخلته وفق شهود
العيان كانت كبيره للغايه تقدر بعشرات
الاليات في كل منطقه وكان قد هنا حصل
مداهمات ايضا للمنازل والعبت بمقتنياتها
ومحتوياتها ومن ثم اقتيد المعتقلون كما
يجري في كل ليله الى معسكرات للتحقيق معهم
بتهمه مقاومه الاحتلال يضاف الى ذلك كما
قلت هذا المشهد من خلفي وهو لاحد المنشات
هنا في بلده حزمه التي قامت سلطات
الاحتلال بهدمها خلال همم الليله الماضيه
وفجر وهذا اليوم بزراء عاشت عاده هي ما
تقوم بالاعلان انها غير قانونيه وكان ذلك
يحتاج همم الى همم تراخيص منها دائما
وتعتبر ان هذه الجهه التي هدمت فيها هذه
المنشات هي تابعه لبلديه القدس بالاساس
ليس كالجانب الاخر من الشارع وهذه من
المفارقات العجيبه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
ان نفس الشارع جانب منه بعد الاحتلال
والجانب الاخر يتبع لبلديه القدس ولذلك من
نفذ كانت جرافات همم تابعه لبلديه القدس
قريبا من هنا ايضا التصعيد مستقبلا كما
يبدو وهذا ما تحمله نظر ما يصرح به بعض
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين هناك الخان الاحمر
ايضا وهو ما تبيت له احزاب الصهيونيه
الدينيه والمتطرفون بالحكومه الحاليه ان
يعود الى التصعيد ضد هذه المنطقه بهدف
اخلاقها كذلك في منطقه الخليل ليتهدد همم
الاجراءات الاحتلاليه تتهدد مساء في
الرياضه المنطقه الاخرى وواضح بان هناك
اطماع عادت اليها هذه الاحزاب المفرطه في
التطرفها اذا اردنا ان نضع همم الحمله
حمله تصيد الاسرائيليه سواء والمداهمات
والاعتقالات او همم
اقتحاماتها عند في الضفه الغربيه اذا
اردنا نضعها في سياقها السياسي داخل
اسرائيل
تبقى التقديرات اول عن لدى الفلسطينيين
بان هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه المفرطه في
تطرفها هي تتجه نحو ان اصبح ذلك منهجا
بالنسبه لها وليس مجرد عمليات متفرقه وهذا
قد يميزها عن الحكومات السابقه هناك ثلاثه
عشر شهيدا فلسطينيه اخرهم كان بالامس الذي
قتلوه بدم بارد امام نجله عند مدخل قريه
سلوان وهناك الكثير من من قتلوا في منذ
بدايه العام ومع الاعتقالات هذه الليله
يصل عدد المعتقلين منذ بدايه عام الى نحو
200 لذلك يرى كثيرون ان اسرائيل قد تلجا
الى تصدير ازماتها الداخليه وتحويلها الى
تصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وذلك يستقيم
مع اطماع الجهات اليمنيه المفرطه في
الحكومه الحاليه وايضا لان لديهم مخططات
بعيده المدى يريدون تنفيذها خلال وجود مثل
هذه تعذر على الحكومات السابقه تنفيذها
اولها ما يستهدف المنطقه سي وهي الممتده
فوق 62% من مساحه الضفه الغربيه فقد يصل
الامر بعد ان حذروا البناء والتواجد
الفلسطيني فيها يصل للامر الى الاعداد الى
ضمها وهي منطقه مقتظه بالمستوطنات صحيح
لكنها تشكل 62% من الضفه الغربيه او قد
يعود الى المخطط الذي اقر لهم به الرئيس
ترامب في حينه والذي يسمح لهم ضم اجزاء من
الضفه الغربيه خاصه في شماليه غور الاردن
وبعض المناطق الاخرى الغربيه منطقه بيت
لحم هذا ما يخططونها الامر الثاني هذه
الحكومه الحاليه بترتيبتها الحاليه
والمتطرفه والعقائديه الايديولوجيه التي
تريد ان تحكم حسب قوانين وشريعه التوراه
هؤلاء لا يقرون بوجود الفلسطينيين الكعب
ولا يعترفون له بمعنى انهم لا يريدون
الفلسطينيين اما ان يكونوا مجرد تاكلين في
هذه المنطقه ولكن بدون اي حقوق وطنيه اخرى
وفقه ما جاء في برامجهم السياسيه لذا
وتحويل السيطره على الاداره المدنيه في
الحكم العسكري وكذلك على حرس الحدود الى
الوزيرين المتطرفين بنجبيرتش واضح بانه قد
تم تاسيس ماء وصفه بعض المسؤولين الكبار
في اسرائيل ومنهم وزراء دافعي دفاع سابقين
ورؤساء اركان الى ميليشيات او الى جيوش
خاصه بهذا الاسم
يتحكموا بكل تفصيله صغيره في حياه فلسطين
المحتله